signori 2018 e qua il mas che lancia le
sue tesla nello spazio garazie noi qua
sulla terra cosa facciamo ambulanze nel
2018 ci penso io siamo tornati su gaza
in glory e hanno aggiunto scienza
missilistica specie di nonno jacques se
così vogliamo chiamarlo nonno ciak nero
però cosa è successo li vorrei iniziare
a capire come funziona sta roba visto
che non ho ancora non è non è così non è
chiaro quale ragazzi e dovrei riuscire
ad arrivare al traguardo tensione che
fenomeno a devo non era fino ad arrivare
porca vacca macello aspetta fede ci
arrivo guardalo quanto forte bene perché
non vedo la telecamera questo gioco dai
suicidi o non riesco a girarla ma
neanche per sbaglio ok c'è l'hanno fatto
da dio se non fosse per la telecamera
lega porca eva marta vedo cose piano
piano non è proprio il gioco che mi
aspettavo però
porca vacca poter allungare una la
manina un po di più possiamo togliere la
musica di sottofondo leggermente
fastidio e questo è solo il primo di
venti livelli che hanno messo non oso
immaginare gli altri ragazzi
sei il migliore grazie non c'era bisogno
di dirlo lo sapevo già ragazzi cosa ci
fate esattamente come ci siete arrivati
soprattutto non ci sono porte qua se
avete bisogno di un passaggio ditemelo è
che io sono qua lui sicuramente arrivato
a destinazione lei no devo arrivare una
donna che bordello no ma dai mi fate
vedere la testata che posso tirare al
tizio mentre girato tra l'altro
ambulanze nel 2018 ci penso io
non è un uomo non è un supereroe e volto
di più altro che il maschio che inventa
e tesla faccio io che è meglio ma io
posso sci armi con la sedia o mio dio
non avevi capito sta roba
oggi la telecamera mito girare io bene
ok
ora sei fantastico grazie però dice
anche mia mamma è la madonna che è
successo sono partito smonto o non vale
che succede hanno investito cos'è il
laser ma per caso perfetto ma poche
balle che vale che vale che vale che
valeva bene a non è un checkpoint quello
porca eva aiuto
è un casino raga non posso mai farlo
tutto impossibile da schivare no vabbè
se ciao è un checkpoint
non è vero nella vita al piano per
l'amore di gesù
ok ma tenaci incredibile o amen
traguardo de rigo non è vero nel mondo a
me la sento naga me la sento velocissimo
[Musica]
porca vacca che male c'è un brutto
rapporto con gli alberi in sto gioco
prova
sì ma stai calmo scemi a lanciarmi gli
aeroplani piano piano piano piano piano
piano piano ma rilancia mica addosso
porca vacca stato il mio computer non
riesce neanche a caricare l'impatto
talmente forte ok ok ok ok no alle bombe
no e buon vino le bombe devo arrivare
cosa non hanno capito
porca vacca non c'ero mai accessi e
ragano va bene senza te lo giuro
infattibile oddio oddio mica un orgasmo
[Musica]
ok ragazzi io avrei anche una vita oltre
questo gioco possiamo finire grazie a
gesù
ho investito uno chissenefrega questo io
lo chiamo lsd
oh mio dio è il bello che ci sto anche
riuscendo quello che mi fa spavento
[Musica]
sei come un dio ma anche di più grazie
ceramente sommesso niente bene
sempre sotto effetto di lsd però va beh
sì ma non è che ti devi drogare ogni
volta che fai un inizio un livello per
cortesia macchine che poteva per pulmini
che volano mazza da baseball giganti che
era un po anche i trequarti devo dire
occhio al laser pochi allarmi che nonno
laser rega un rebus non è persona seria
laser e laser e il pulmino sono vivo
sono più è la forza nel lsd oh mio dio
va bene bene ho preso c'è poi chi se ne
frega bella molto bella sì tua sorella
che sbalzi riga basta se ce l'ha fatta
héctor zamboni ce la posso fare anch'io
vorrei di ragazzi miei abbiamo finito
tutti i livelli
come si chiama è stato beata però finiti
tutti chi ha finito completamente sto
gioco
essi sono i traguardi nella vita non tra
la fidanzata a farsi una famiglia no
questo è ragazzi miei
spero che vi sia piaciuto spero di
avergli evocato un po i ricordi non sa
che tutto questo non imitate queste cose
c'è è un po difficile evitare queste
cose però nel dubbio non fate però vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi questo era il
tutorial su come andare a scuola veloce
con sensori prigione quanto mi piace
anche ai sette minuti dal fischio
stagione si scateni ci vediamo
[Musica]